we have our first question from juan
thank you for
uh sending in another question we i
remember hearing from you last week
um so hwan wants to know if the study is
longitudinal
since
i think genie went out did we lose genie
oops
that's all right i can i can take over
um well
let me start by once again thank you
with ellis that was a really really
fantastic presentation
uh and i'll pick up from where genie
left off
on the question from juan who is asking
if the study was longitudinal
because the sample sizes changed between
each range of things that you were
showing
back yeah sorry
we all face internet problems right um
i think that this question actually is
like why are there different numbers of
patients
like it's not the same it's not and
because they're looking at
they're asking different questions so in
that first figure that i showed you
where they're just looking at the
presence
or the detectable amounts of antibodies
they're looking just to see if
all of the 285 patients if they're able
to see if they
have igm or igg antibodies now
out of those patients you can't really
look at when
the time course of the production of the
antibodies so
they then took out data sets where they
have multiple serum samples
so about 200 of the patients they only
had one blood sample from the patient
that they're able to analyze from
and from that one sample you can only
see oh i see igm
oic igg and they use that in a
particular
graph i mean the other data sets where
they're looking at from
being negative for certain antibodies to
being positive
they can only use the ones that they
have multiple serum samples
so yes the the samples differ based on
the questions that they were trying to
ask
i think thanks i can hear you i can hear
your blue jays
in your background oh yeah i know i've
been like sorry
i've been using the phone to detect so
loud
yeah lovely though yes it is actually
um okay well let's go for question two
then from um
urania davis who asks how long the igg
needs to be present
in order for us to consider a patient
immune we have no idea
um and so yeah we're really trying
uh well not me in particular but
scientists are really trying hard to
figure out um if one
does it is there a difference with how
much igg antibodies you're producing
does it matter if the igg antibodies are
neutralizing or not
and also the antibodies do seem to
decrease
over time and so because this is a
recent situation we
don't have the samples necessary to kind
of answer that
question and so someone's been infected
in february it's only been what three
months
and so we can't really predict what
their immune system is going to do
in the next six months um but based on
other
infections that are similar to stars
clove too like sars and mers
immunity seems to be around a year or
two
so scientists are kind of going off of
that but once again we're still unsure
that's great well um we'll move on to
question
three then from joanne gensert uh
he asks about subtypes of iggs
yes talk a little bit about those yeah
so you're getting really nitty-gritty um
so they are um i think
four subtypes of igg the authors do not
indicate what subtypes they are
i briefly read something
um no i think that was something else
i'm not sure if i've read a paper that
specified the subtype of igg that
they're looking at it may be in the new
paper
um that rockefeller university put out
because they actually did a sequence
analysis of all the antibodies that are
produced
and i'm pretty sure they might have a
better idea of what those subtypes of
igg are
um so they are clonal differences with
the the igg antibodies that are produced
and these clonal differences do seem to
have a connection with
how good they are at neutralizing
infection
but that's a good question all right
cool
i think related maybe is uh joanne asks
again was there a correlation between
the different serial conversion
times i think and the depth versus
survival
or release from the hospital and that's
an interesting question because we
didn't actually see
uh some of their samples
yeah um so from the paper
i don't think they i don't think any of
the patients succumb to infection
um
so i don't know the answer to that so
they did not follow the patients after
they're released from the hospitals
so i can't i can't actually answer that
question based on what the authors
presented yeah yeah this is an important
question and i think
you know folks are on it and hopefully
we'll get more data
uh i'll give a bigger picture of that
later on
okay that's great and um aditi is back
with another question
uh question five for today she asked if
the igg antibodies are specific to spike
proteins or if they're just a general
response
to the virus that's a really good
question yeah that is a good question
um so with the igg antibodies so in this
particular test
the acid that they use the anagen that
they use to detect the igg and igm
antibodies
is an antigen that has both um
parts of the spike protein and parts of
the nuclear protein
um and so they're kind of like lumping
them in one
um studies are showing that you can get
igg antibodies response to the spike
protein
and the nuclear protein but i'm unsure
of the other parts of the virus so it is
specific
um and i'm not sure if it correlates
with the different types of igg subtypes
that you're producing or clonal
antibodies that you're producing
that's a good question yeah i think
there's a there's a test um
that uh some folks that have produced i
don't know who made this test but
there's a test that's an antibody test
that's specific to the end protein which
is the nucleocapsid protein that
surrounds the rna
and then the one that you talked about
which is specific to that
there are some and i think the paper
addressed this a little where they
looked
at um cross reactivity of
i think it's the end protein of both
stars cov1
and sars cove ii and there seems to be
slight cross reactivity with a couple of
the sample sets
so the way to develop the assay to
bypass any like false
positives they incorporated a peptide
that incorporates parts of the n and
parts of the s
so they can weed out any of the false
positive of antibodies that may be
there from a previous sars type
infection and not the current sars co2
the test i think right now that quest
diagnostic is using and the one that i
spoke about in um um in my first
presentation they were using the spike
protein for those antibody tests and i
think the majority
that or the few that fda has approved
for emergency purposes
do use the s protein or the spike
protein for the antibody testing
yeah it's so weird one of the things
that i learned through this whole
process
is how amazing antibodies are like
like i'm like oh great they developed an
antibody test it never even occurred to
me that
to ask is this the right antibody test
you know
i feel like my mind is blown through all
of that no it's a lot
the immune response the immune system
the human body is fascinating
right and then we're also combating that
with a fascinating virus
and so things like a catch-22 trying to
understand both
i know i i feel a little bit bad about
the
level of excitement of science i feel
around something that's so destructive
to humans
you know it's just like weird balance
but as a cancer
yeah as a cancer researcher i can
definitely relate to that
yeah oh yeah yeah for sure great so we
have a question from marva
can neutralizing antibodies be made in
the lab that's a really good question so
that paper that i pointed out
um in the end that rockefeller put out
about a week ago
through the preprint bioarchive their
goal
is to somehow or is to make these
antibodies in the lab
so what they're looking at they're
looking at the different patients
they're looking at their antibodies
they're sequencing the antibodies that
they have
and they're trying to use that sequence
to produce the same antibodies that seem
to have really high neutralizing
capabilities
and so if we can pretty much replicate
those
really strong neutralizing antibodies
that patients have produced in their
immune systems
we can make more of that in the lab to
use as drug targets so that's exactly
what um
scientists at rockefeller are working on
right now so yep you can
yeah i think it's the nuisance triglabs
so look up michelle newsome swag's work
uh they've been asking for people
there's a there was a clinical study and
it might still be ongoing that if
anybody's recovered from covet 19
they want to see what your antibodies
are like so that they can
base therapies off of the super antibody
producers
right so it's really coming together you
know
yeah it kind of relates to some of the
sort of earlier i don't know if people
are still walking working on that but
some of the earlier studies of people
who are trying to get serum out of
patients whoever
recovered to use as therapeutic itself
right
yeah so you're having patients who
and i think the thought was like if you
had really bad symptoms and you
recovered that
there's a high likelihood that you have
really good antibodies so they were
asking patients to donate their blood
samples so personally i have
um someone close to me who had covet 19
and her doctor asked her like hey
can we have some of your blood so we can
use your serum
hopefully to um use it as a treatment
for other patients
so that's the whole idea behind it yeah
same for me i have a very close friend
who's actually a nurse and has been
working in the icus who ended up with
covid
and she came from this from the angle of
watching first-hand people you know
suffer and
many not recover from the disease and
she was like take my blood
and do everything you can with it so i
think people are really looking to
to donate in under the circumstances
yeah it's great that people are being
that active as well
so thank you everybody who's doing that
by the way absolutely
um okay we have another question from
joanne who asks if the
samples were collected postmortem and if
there is a tissue bank of these samples
poor smarts and meaning after they i
think on patients that died from covet
um so not in this paper um so all of
these samples were taken
once they were in the hospital so they
were admitted into the hospital
i guess they signed a consent to be a
part of this clinical study
and they took how much ever samples they
were able to take
that could be one or that could be a
series of three like i mentioned
um but they haven't mentioned using
sample sets from people who
pass from covet 19 and i'm not sure if
there's a
tissue bank of samples i don't know
it's a good question i'm not sure but
all of that together yeah
that's good but all of the patients that
were used in this trial were patients
who
survived them yeah so they were all
hospitalized and at some point they were
all released from the hospital
great well thank you so much for
presenting i think that's all the
questions we have yeah that's what i was
checking now
yeah i put the the so there was a
question around giving the link to the
rockefeller paper so that's there
um and i think that's fairly
i think we're we're pretty good one of
the things that i really loved about
this paper is
the power you know i think we we all
feel that like statistics must involve
you know in order for us to make any
kind of like real
um clinical uh like
recommendations or suggestions it
requires hundreds of thousands of data
points which i think for like
medications that we all
you know we can't have a you know cold
and flu medication
that's specific to our bodies at this
point in time though in cancer
we want to have individualized right and
so that's sort of
this push and pull between the aggregate
uh data and
understanding how the trends are so that
we can predict what happens in a
population
versus the individual response i think
is is a really fascinating way to
to approach the science here and even
with like if we're looking at the
combined dataset and the aggregate data
it's really nice because like the
bioarchive paper from rockefeller
they're pinpointing individuals who have
this really high
neutralizing antibody response and using
that particular individual
to utilize that for a population and so
i think both are very important for us
to look at the population on a whole
but also if we can pinpoint someone who
has like
you know slightly outlier that we can
hijack some of their mechanisms to
utilize for the rest of the population
yeah i'm just thinking also historically
when you look at outliers
um like as an example um there was a set
of outliers
in like an island over in the south
pacific
that helped us to understand like hdl
metabolism
right and and sometimes these genetic
outliers are
open up doors for us to understand some
new phenomenon about the human body
uh so um it's really good that we are
taking all this data in
and that there's people who can try to
make sense of it in some way shape or
form and the style and the and
put applying the different styles of
reasoning uh
onto a question so that there's multiple
angles being explored for any specific
question i think is really important as
well
and the and the fact that it's you know
as you mentioned earlier such
a strong collaborative effort involving
different hospitals and everything which
is such an important part of science
yeah um any last words odellus to share
about the paper
or anything like this um
no i don't have any other comments
or questions um
so there is one actually one more
question from facebook and it's around
igms versus i guess it's maybe igms and
i'm
i'm
assuming it's in the context of igm
versus ihg it says here
igm is lower you know and
you know and and and i maybe we can talk
about it from the right
yeah um hey ferdi um so uh
so i think one of the main takeaways
is that igm seems to be maybe important
for triggering the response for igg
i don't know if there's a way that we
can
prevent the lowering or if that would
help
because even when it igm is lowered
you're still
getting production of igg and i think
the important takeaway
is that we want the igg levels um
and it doesn't seem to be that igm may
be that important for like
you know combating this infection well
and that's just
me thinking about all the other papers
that i've read um maybe scientists are
realizing that it does have another role
to
play but i'm not sure